Julian Zietlow
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht wo ich
anfangen soll Julian Zietlow ist 38
Jahre alt deutscher Personal Trainer
influencer und fitnessunternehmer ja
drunter anderem das
nahrungsergänzungsmittelunternehmen
Rocker nutrition gegründet und hat mit
seiner Frau Alina Schulte im Hof 2
Kinder ihr fragt euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich Mensch Luca wenn der
Julian Siedlung doch so ein geiler Typ
ist warum machst du denn ein Video über
den
er es gibt einige Gründe fangen wir
erstmal ganz vorne an Julian ist mit
seiner Frau und den beiden Kindern auf
die thailändische Insel Koh Phangan
geflogen auf jeden Fall ein bisschen
Urlaub gemacht hat eine schöne Zeit doch
irgendwann muss die Kinder natürlich
logischerweise wieder in die Schule
deswegen ist die Frau von Julian zieht
nur die Alina schon mal vorher
abgerissen mit den Kindern und der
julian hat sich gedacht nee nur ein paar
Tage chill noch ein bisschen ich ruhe
mich aus er ist halt Geschäft ne da
braucht man eine Pause wird dann
allerdings zu etwas ganz verrücktem den
urplötzlich hat dieser Julian Siedlung
dessen Instagram Feed normalerweise bis
zu diesem Zeitpunkt so aussah voll mit
nahrungsergänzungskram Sport mit seiner
Frau ziemlich viel der plötzlich dann so
Videos hochgeladen wie der auf einmal im
thailändischen Regen mit einer anderen
Frau rumtanzt und alle
und damit meine ich wirklich alle
Kommentare sind gegen ihn
zu Recht neben Fitness Content hat
Julian Zietlow auf seinem YouTube-Kanal
auch unter anderem damals dieses Video
hier veröffentlicht in dem er eine
part-zeremonie mit seiner damaligen Frau
Alina gemacht hat die ja mit den Kindern
abgereist ist mittlerweile auch gesagt
hat dass sie die Scheidung genommen
spirituelle Richtung und hat auch drei
Wochen vor diesem Paar Zeremonie Video
das hier hochgeladen einfach ein zwei
einhalb Stunden Talk über seinen
spiritual awakening und vor dieses Video
hat er dann sogar diesen Disclaimer noch
gepackt dieses Video Dienst zur
Aufklärung Risiko Minimierung und zu
Unterhaltung und soll nicht den Konsum
psychoaktiver Substanzen verherrlichen
so etwas wie risikofreien Konsum
psychoaktiver Substanzen gibt es nicht
der sicherste Konsum ist daher kein
Konsum eben aufgrund solcher Videos
haben sich dann halt Leute gedacht ey
ist der Julian zieht so jetzt wirklich
im Urlaub wo seine Frau schon vorher
abgereist ist so verrückt geworden dass
er solche psychoaktiven Substanz en
selber ausprobiert hat das kann nicht
runter nehmen der hat Kinder zu Hause
die sich Sorgen machen wo ihr Papa ist
das kann doch gar nichts sagen
das ist wie ein Unfall
man will eigentlich nicht hingucken
aber man kann auch nicht weg gucken
Julian zieht los ist unter anderem
bekannt geworden mit seinen Körper
Transformationen er hat Stars dabei
geholfen innerhalb von zehn Wochen zu
ihrem Traumkörper zu gelangen
mittlerweile verhält er sich selber
dabei innerhalb von zehn Wochen seinen
Beruf komplett zu zerstören Kameramann
tut mir auch extrem leid aber auch noch
bis zu diesem Moment dachten sich viele
Leute ey
ist doch ein prank ich dachte das auch
bin ich ganz ehrlich da muss ich mich
mit einschließen safe ich dachte mir
auch das kann doch nicht sein der Typ
hat so eine Verantwortung nicht nur sein
Unternehmen gegenüber den Riesen
Imageschaden davontragen werden und
gerade auch zu tragen haben sondern aus
seiner Familie gegenüber der wird doch
nicht urplötzlich da irgendeine random
Frau die im Urlaub kennenlernt als eine
neue Liebe betiteltaschen
[Musik]
und irgendwann deutschland wartet seine
Frau mit den Kindern
die sich fragen wo es Papa ich schreibe
die Caption mal für dich um Baby bevor
ich dich getroffen habe hatte ich eine
wunderschöne Frau und ein wunderschönes
Leben von dem viele nur träumen konnten
ich habe all das zurückgelassen hab mit
Drogen angefangen und bin jetzt der
Vater der ich niemals sein wollte ab
diesem Zeitpunkt wusste wirklich jeder
dass Julian Ziegler diesen ganzen Lachs
ernst meint dass das kein soziales
Experiment mehr ist dass das kein prank
mehr ist sondern dass er wirklich seine
kompletten Sinne in Thailand verloren
hat und wirklich krank im Drogenkonsum
stecken geblieben ist ich meine der Typ
hat vor anderthalb Wochen angefangen
Videos hochzuladen wie er so am Tanzen
ist
mit der caption ich bin Gott
dieses Bild ja der letzte Sonntag
hochgeladen bist du was die Caption ist
you are my drug except auf Emma tschüss
kidding
Not aber wer ist eigentlich dieses Mädel
da an seiner Seite hate Kolos
Kajal kann ja aus Russland
macht auch nichts
beste Voraussetzung für so eine Frau und
Kinder zu verlassen die haben auch
übrigens eine richtig schöne
kennenlernengeschichte
vom Fitnessstudio
romantisch aber zurück zu Julian der hat
dann auf jeden Fall dieses Bild hier
hochgeladen mit einem fetten
Knutschfleck am Hals wahrscheinlich von
einem Elefanten oder Wert und Fetten
Mund you can cances someone givesh free
Julian abgerechnet wird am Strand
abgerechnet wird in der Entzugsklinik
normale Menschen
macht dein ganzen Scheiß es ist wirklich
komplett Wain aber macht doch nicht
öffentlich deine Kinder werden das
irgendwann sehen und ihr müsst checken
Kinder sind nicht so dass sie sich
denken oh mein Papa der will uns nicht
mehr keine Ahnung okay wir leben weiter
nein das Wort für psychische Schäden bei
den Kindern die denken sich dass sie
irgendwas falsch gemacht haben und das
wird in ihrer Zukunft noch so krass
mental beeinflussen dieser Typ lebt
komplette Egozentrik aus und versteckt
das unter dem Deckmantel des
spirituellen mein RTL
bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt habe ich mir
allerdings gedacht Mensch zu dem Thema
Luca da brauchst jetzt keine Youtube
Videos zu machen dass du dich mal zu
irgendeiner Geschichte äußerst da muss
schon einiges passieren ich habe mit
Sandra darüber im Podcast zwei Folgen
hintereinander gesprochen weil immer
wieder neue Sachen von Julian Ziegler
hochgeladen wurden wo wir uns mal lustig
gemacht haben wo wir darüber
philosophiert haben was für Drogen
genommen hat hat vielleicht angehört auf
Spotify doch jetzt kann das krasseste
Julian Zietlow hat einen neuen Account
gegründet namens vor Junkies also 4
Drogenabhängige unterspricht er mit
seiner Kate nach Freundin und noch einem
anderen Typen über
es ist schwierig zu beschreiben
das Ding geht eine Stunde ich habe mir
das komplett angeschaut es ist um es
kurz zu fassen wie so ein Doktor Sommer
Bravo Sex Talk geführt von Midlife
Crisis opfern
und einer Frau
die kein einziges Wort versteht kurz
nachdem der Podcast dann allerdings
online gegangen ist hat Julian auch
schon wieder etwas gepostet
in video
da ist Julian wahrscheinlich gerade auf
einem DMT Trip das ist das stärkste
Halluzinogen der Welt eigentlich nur
noch gefehlt das ronnen irgendwie ein
Tornado im Hintergrund findet doch sein
neuer Post
in der vor sieben Stunden auf Instagram
hochgeladen hat
der Top meiner Ansicht nach wirklich
fast alles
[Musik]
genauso Klinge ich nach dem indischen
Essen auf Toilette
nur ohne diesen komischen Elefanten Kuss
am Hals jedes Mal wenn ich mir gedacht
habe Mensch das geht nicht schlimmer
dann kommt der Julian Ziegler aus seiner
thailändischen Ecke und wackelt
komplettes spirituelle drogenshippe nach
oben drauf sogar ein
Bestattungsunternehmen hat unter seinen
Beiträgen kommentiert chapeau Karrieren
schneller beerdigt als wir es jemals
könnten ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt
nicht wie ich in diesem Video hier auf
dem Punkt kommen soll wie ich ein Ende
finden kann oder wie wenn Fazit daraus
ziehen können
[Musik]
keine macht den Drogen
Drink water
das ist
so verloren